i'm sorry
we're gonna play spiciest curry
telephone which means we're gonna go to
one place we're gonna try the spiciest
curry there and then ask them
if they weren't gonna eat spicy curry
from their place where they go to eat
the spiciest curry and we'll go on and
on and on and on until we keel over
from fire [ __ ] uncle colin was busy and
they were doing curry
so they brought me i don't get it
because i'm indian it's a curry thing
you're in me i think i can handle it
like how spicy could curry be how spicy
we are looking for the spiciest curry in
la
any idea where we should start i think
you should go to gelata oh god
it might be the spiciest but if they can
find an even spicier place for you that
would be
incredible and i'm sorry
we're starting with thai curry thai
curry has that kind of like fusion of
like both the south asian and the east
asian spices so are we rating them
based on like the poops after or like
how much does it burn going in
and how much does it burn going out the
spiciest thing we have is a dynamite
challenge but
that's way crazy what's the challenge
the challenge is
[ __ ] if you get a free dessert let's do
it is your bubble ready
it's definitely clenched oh my god
that's not even green cucumbers and
pears on ice to help with the heat like
that's legit chili paste
my mouth is watering right now oh my
gosh
my body doesn't like it my stomach is
burning i'm sorry hiccupping
i'm crying oh it's coming back it's not
going away you're gonna find me on the
bathroom floor halfway through my poop
dead
i'm pissed why did you order that
freddie and steven are fighting we lost
in the curry one
dear viewers if you see a speck on the
screen it is thai iced tea
that freddy just spat out at us it's
over look at freddie
if you weren't going to eat spicy curry
here where would you go eat curry
i definitely go to curry house in little
tokyo
i think it's not as spicy as us but it's
pretty spicy
guys i feel nauseous that is not sitting
well i'm still
pissed i actually thought birdie was
going to
murder me so where are we going to next
guys curry house
here we are at curry house we're about
to eat this spicy curry
i don't think it's going to be spicy at
the last place but let's do it let's go
it smells great this smells like hungry
like curry
that is the light bulb yeah i want more
i kind of like the gravy vibe
you know how i'm scarred from last place
it's like burning those scars no it just
tastes like mild curry
oh [ __ ] is that chili oil yeah ah
stephen that
immediately sent a signal to my stomach
to get ready it's like doesn't burn your
mouth but it like burns you
it like gives you some chest hair i need
that this is a good spicy this is a
spice that i can eat
can't wait to see my boyfriend and
breathe in his face taste 10 out of 10
spice 6 out of 10. one of the waiters
suggested an indian curry
skate of india here we come put me on
the dance floor right here
i'm sure i'm sure hey we're here gate of
india
i can make it it's really really spicy i
can make it happen these are our mango
lassies it's a legit
like smoothie it is a sweet yogurt drink
this is good
it will eliminate spice all right
this looks spicy
here's the last spot that is the best
combination of spice and taste
that we've had spicy yeah it's like
creeping up i like that like andrew
that's my ish man flavors were so good
it was very spicy
i know that i'm biased but i think this
one's the best disclaimer she is half
indian
so that dynamite challenge though oh
hell no hashtag feast mode fans
mouths open butthole clinched
my stomach is killing me right now i
think it had the opposite effect on me
like i'm stopped up so my anus is still
clenched
to be honest i feel okay what i woke up
at 4 am this morning
you know like when it gets so bad you
like stripped down
that there is actually a dynamite
challenge book people write testimonials
of their experience trying the anime
challenge
october 2nd 2012 chris s i came i saw i
was deep throated by the devil